what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
all right so the Revenge of the Green
Lantern's Prelude is a maze and gets
super good actually we'll get to see
Batman become a Green Lantern like or at
least what it would look like with him
as a Green Lantern it's only for a
moment but it is free Stella it's pretty
awesome that's where the things I really
loved about Geoff Johns writing is this
like you have to see these cool little
moments characters that you would never
see put on Lantern ring suddenly become
a lantern and it is it
it looks amazing Batman as a Green
Lantern looks incredibly amazing it's
one of the coolest things we're going to
see so initially it's picked up with Hal
Jordan on on OA and it's actually
talking to us a lot now the reason why
this is revenge of the Green Lantern
Prelude is because of the fact that the
the main revenge of the Green Lantern
story is going to deal with the fallout
the direct fallout of emerald Twilight
now for those the guys who were new to
the Green Lantern mythos if I bring up
the name parallax these guys are
probably going to think of parallax is
like the giant yellow entity and that
makes sense because that's what he is
now he's a-- he's the entity he's that
you know the representation of the
emotional spectrum with regards to fear
but back in the 1990s parallax was just
a name that Hal Jordan gave himself and
so in Parratt when when how Jordan just
sorted running around operating as
parallax uh he killed basically all the
Green Lantern's you know he really took
the Rings and so on and so forth
destroyed them all like his ring was
recreated and given the kyle rayner but
uh he was basically just a bad guy and
so what we've been to the Green
Lantern's is going to do is actually
going to show us that not all of those
original Green Lantern's died that some
of them lived but they suddenly been
held away they've been kept in stasis by
cyborg superman ever since they're
they're presumed ever since the events
of emerald twilight took place now of
course the reason why this is
significant is because of the fact that
Salak basically sits down for what Hal
Jordan says look man like the guardians
of the universe is basically absorbed
you this they've welcomed you back into
the fold they said you're no longer a
guy who's to be shunned you're a member
of the Green Lantern Corps who's to be
celebrated and really the greatest of
the Green Lantern Corps but what's the
Locke says is just because the the
Guardians have forgiven you doesn't mean
everybody else has basically said you're
going to want to watch your back because
the veterans know what you did they've
heard about what you did those
individuals who are brand new will hear
about what you did and some individuals
may have lost friends and family some
people inherited the ring
of their mothers and fathers and so
because of that they're going to blame
you for the loss of the ones that they
care about and if you're not careful
it's going to cost you your life so
again what this does is it shows us that
just because the Green Lanterns doesn't
mean there's not infighting it doesn't
mean if there's not bickering and
arguing and if some individuals just
can't get along and that there aren't
grudges being held all of that stuff
still exists and that's why it's so cool
is because Geoff Johns does not take
this standard of well they're all Green
Lanterns and they're all best friends so
he says they're Green Lanterns but a lot
of them don't like each other and a lot
of them would rather kill other Green
Lantern's
and see somebody wear that lantern ring
so again it's really kind of a cool idea
here what we do is again because of the
fact that Hal Jordan largely focuses on
events that are on earth we transition
over to Gotham City and the reason why
is because of the fact that Batman
informs Hal Jordan said there's someone
running around called the tattoo man now
of course the cool thing about this is
Geoff Johns draws on the existing Hal
Jordan mythos remember when Green
Lantern rebirth was launched and Hal
Jordan came back in the whole history of
parallax and everything was explained
geoff johns it wasn't like a hard reboot
geoff johns didn't wipe the slate clean
from the Green Lantern mythos we can
treat it that way but it isn't that way
and truth the entire history of how
Jordan remains intact he was first given
the Green Lantern ring by Evans or he
went on to become you know one of the
most capable Green Lantern's he was of
course he really had a Sinestro as his
main villain eventually he became
parallax Kyle Rayner took his place as
the last Green Lantern and then we went
into Green Lantern rebirth back when
when everything was kind of uh kind of
started over again by Geoff Johns but
the reason why I bring that up is
because how Jordan makes reference to a
guy who is actually the original
tattooed man what house wooden says is
that the only tattooed man he knows
about is a guy by the name of Abel
Terran naval Terran was the tattooed man
for quite some time and basically had
the ability to make his tattoos take
physical form but the new one is a guy
by the name of Mark Richards now Mark
Richards is actually just kind of like
what we get here in the story is really
all we get for his character barring you
know Final Crisis but prior to that all
we had here was all that we got he was
just a guy he was a former US Marine he
just showed up on the scene one day he
had the ability to turn his tattoos into
physical beams and then those those
tattoos will carry out his own wishes
attack people different things like that
the most recent victim is a guy by the
name of Rosen and this guy was basically
killed and then you know
what was written on his chest was simply
the phrase weakness women and that seems
to be the basis behind the tattooed man
is he literally goes around and kills
people for their sins now the other half
of this is that that man really kind of
looks down on Hal Jordan now we know the
bat man doesn't like lanterns and all of
this really stems back to Emerald
Twilight well I wouldn't say that Batman
and Hal Jordan were ever the best of
friends I would say that Hal Jordan was
the last person that man expected to
turn villains to turn into a bad guy and
so that issued a lot of betrayal on
behalf of that man he's never really
liked lanterns following the events of
Emerald Twilight now he does hold a
special grudge for Hal Jordan and
because of this you know with Hal Jordan
despite the fact that he showed up he
cast off his identity as parallax he's
no longer the spectre it's just Hal
Jordan the pilot and Green Lantern
Batman still wants to get even of course
he does this by punching the heck out of
him he punches the absolute heck out of
him and that's it no muss no fuss that's
one of the really cool thing this one of
these I think about guys I think I don't
think guys hold grudges for a lengthy
amount of time that was a lesson I
learned in middle school in middle
school two girls would start fighting at
the beginning of the year and they would
fight for the whole year the whole
school year with guys it wasn't like
that guys like yeah man like I don't
like you then they fight any they were
friends or they just didn't like each
other from then on out but they wouldn't
find everyday you know they wouldn't
take potshots at each other and stuff
like that but the document here that
were there differences more or less set
aside even if only for the time being
what Jeff Jones does is he actually
gives us some really cool insight into
the differences between Batman and and
Hal Jordan what we know about Batman is
Batman is a is a creature of the night I
mean that's his thing he hides in the
shadows you know he pops out of cracks
in the ground field he shows up out of
nowhere and subdues various villains he
relies on fear in order to ensure that
those individuals who would commit a
crime don't commit a crime or at the
very least think twice about it
Howard on the other hand does not view
himself that way in his mind he wants to
be a beacon for villains he wants all
villains everywhere to see him and his
motivation behind that is when he says
the reason why is this well he wants the
villains to see him instead of anybody
else he wants the villains to target him
instead of targeting innocent people so
again
it's actually a really cool philosophy
between the two of them but this fight
with regards to mark Rogers with regard
to the tattooed man is pretty
short-lived but the reason why this is a
pre loo
for a revenge of the of the Green
Lanterns is become the fact that in
their conflict what Mark Richards does
is he confirms the fact that the various
tattoos he has on his body are in
relation to the sins that people have
committed murder wrath greed arrogance
different things like that the sins of
man the things that basically Bend
people towards tendencies regarding evil
as opposed to good and what he does is
he look at it looks at Hal Jordan and he
says there are so many sins on you
murder betrayal lies deceit you are a
sinful man and is basically geoff johns
harkening to the idea that there's a lot
of history that how Jordan hasn't dealt
with and that's true how she wouldn't
just kind of showed up on the scene and
said hey I'm back I'm back to my normal
self guys I'm ready to be a superhero
again and that was it that was really
all we got up to this point there was no
indication no inclination that he had
any intention to make up for his past
misdeeds and let's talk about that more
when we get to revenge of the Green
Lantern's but of course with Batman
being the other half of this equation
Batman joins into the fray and then
subdues Mark Richards pretty quick I
mean it's like it's a two page battle I
mean there's really not much about it
but that was the basis was to basically
take the guy out and call it a day now
the other half of this the reason why
one of the real ways that we get to see
Green Lantern Batman is when Hal Jordan
sits down with him and says I want to
show you something I want you to do
something and when Batman turns around
he gives them her hands him the Green
Lantern ring and he simply says put it
on put it on and try to use it now oh
really a lot of this is because of the
fact that as Hal Jordans gift to Batman
with regards to the Green Lantern ring
Geoff Johns was kind of explaining this
to us and simply saying the ability to
overcome great fear is fear of the
unknown but fear of your own past it's
fear of the mistakes that you've made
and fear that you may fall right back
down to those mistakes again with
regards to Batman it feeds on the fear
that he has in himself Batman's not
really afraid of villains that man is
not really afraid of bad guys he's not
really afraid of ultra powerful people
like Superman despite the fact of their
heroes
Batman is afraid of the fact that he
won't honor his parents Batman is afraid
of the fact that he's going to fail the
task that he set for himself now the way
do we know this is because how Jordan
says you can't forget about the things
that happened to you but when you're in
that that space in between the bad
experiences that you've had and your
attempt to let them go that's where the
power of the Ring comes from Batman
harnesses it and is able to harness the
power of the Green Lantern and it is the
coolest looking thing ever
it's so awesome you know and in Hal
Jordan simply says overcome this fear
put that moment behind you put your
childhood fear of Joe Chill put the fear
that you felt when your parents were
shot let that go put that behind you now
Batman's response is I don't want to but
the way that this happens is with him
basically conjuring constructs any
conscious constructs of his parents and
that's what's so cool about this is
because of all the things that he could
have conjured the one thing he wanted to
see was his parents and it's a really
touching moment it's a beautifully done
moment because right now this is not
Bruce wayne/batman it's not the scary
terrifying Bruce wayne/batman this is
the kid Batman this is eight nine ten
year old Bruce Wayne it's what this is
that's why Jeff John's green light man
Jeff John man if God were right in Green
Lantern right now is what it'd look like
right now it is an amazing little bit of
storytelling here so again you know
Bruce wayne/batman listicle II says I
don't want to put this behind me and the
motivation behind this is because of the
fact that if he put his childhood fear
behind him if he put away the fear that
he might not live up to the honor of his
parents if he puts away the fear that
after you know his time as that man is
done that he just hasn't made Gotham
safe then there wouldn't be a reason for
him to be Batman he would basically be
forced to walk away for the mantle and
so for this moment for for right now he
simply says the fear that I have of
failing my parents the fear that I felt
as a child and the anger that I feel now
is my motivation for continuing to be
Batman and I will not rest until Gotham
City is safe and so because of this gift
that Hal Jordan gave to that man it is
basically kind of a mending of rifts is
two of them coming together to a degree
and Batman finally saying thank you you
know I'm glad you're back and so what
this does it just kind of sets the stage
I mean they're not the best of friends
it's not like Green Arrow and Green
Lantern they're not the best of friends
but the various rifts that existed
between the two of them the animosity
that that man have for Hal Jordan is for
the most part beginning to go away but
we're not being said guys we're going to
go ahead and bring this video to an end
if you are new here to come as explained
make sure you guys are the set button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you guys in
the next video peace
[Music]